the largest assistance package yet from
the U.S to Aid Ukraine in its war with
Russia the three billion dollars in
direct Aid to Ukraine includes 50
Bradley Fighting Vehicles it's the first
time the armored carrier will be sent to
Ukraine the package also includes nearly
300 other armored vehicles as well as
air defense systems and anti-tank
Rockets it comes as Vladimir Putin has
called for a ceasefire for Orthodox
Christmas the Russian president attended
a Christmas service alone in a Kremlin
chapel today it was Ian Lee reports
Putin may not be abiding by his own
promise for a peaceful holiday
the guns haven't fallen silent over
Orthodox Christmas but no one in Ukraine
really thought they would especially on
the front lines
they are treacherous enemies
what's the Spire says this Ukrainian
Soldier as Russian Artillery Echoes In
The Distance we have learned not to
trust them
in Bak moot a city that seen months of
some of the fiercest fighting residents
crowd in a shelter for Christmas dinner
they're grateful to charge their phones
a bite to eat and a hot drink to stay
warm people here aren't ready to bet
their lives on a Moscow promise but this
holiday didn't pass without a present
the White House announced three billion
dollars in military aid including the
Bradley infantry Fighting Vehicle the
U.S plans to send about 50 of the proven
Russian tank Killers to Ukraine it'll
take a couple of months to get this
capability fielded to get the ukrainians
trained Mr President
on Friday Senators Jack Reed and Angus
King visited Ukrainian president
vlodimir zielinski in Kiev they told
reporters afterward that zielinski gave
them a shopping list of what he thinks
will help his country win the war I
think what the United States and the
world Community is trying to do is find
the right combination of armored
vehicles that will be most effectively
used by the Ukrainian forces
the United States is being joined by
Germany and France in providing infantry
fighting Vehicles Cold War weapons
designed to rip through Russian tanks
like this one and move troops the
Pentagon says it'll give Ukraine the
ability to change the equation on the
battlefield for CBS Saturday morning Ian
Lee and Kiev